From WBEZ Chicago, it's Ira Glass and His Radio Cowboys.
来自芝加哥WBEZ电台，这里是艾拉·格拉斯和他的无线电牛仔。
[MUSIC - "BONANZA" BY DAVID ROSE]
[音乐 - 大卫·罗斯的《波南扎》]
No, that is definitely not good. All right. Let's try this.
不，那绝对不好。好吧，让我们试试这个。
[MUSIC PLAYING]
[音乐播放中]
No, not that music. How about this one?
不，不是那段音乐。这个怎么样？
[MUSIC PLAYING]
[音乐播放中]
From WBEZ Chicago, it's Journey To Whatever. I'm Ira Glass. From WBEZ Chicago, it's Mouth Noise. I'm Ira Glass. It's Small Moment from WBEZ Chicago, documenting every little thing in this, our American lives. Hello. From WBEZ Chicago, you're listening to Chin Wag Theater.
来自芝加哥WBEZ电台，这里是《通往无论哪里》。我是艾拉·格拉斯。来自芝加哥WBEZ电台，这里是《口部噪音》。我是艾拉·格拉斯。这是来自芝加哥WBEZ电台的《小瞬间》，记录着我们美国生活中的每一件小事。你好。来自芝加哥WBEZ电台，你正在收听的是《闲聊剧场》。
It was when I decided that the name of our radio show should no longer be Your Radio Playhouse, a name which I loved, but many people hated. I'll just say, many people hated that title especially public radio program directors, who told me that they already had radio drama.
那是我决定我们的广播节目不再叫《你的无线电剧场》的时候，那个名字我很喜欢，但很多人讨厌它。我只想说，很多人讨厌那个标题，尤其是公共广播节目的导演们，他们告诉我，他们已经有广播剧了。
And we would explain, "No, no, we don't-- this isn't a radio drama show. It's 'playhouse' like Pee Wee Herman, 'playhouse' like Pee Wee Herman. It's a playhouse. It's a place where people play, but it's also a stage. It's a double meaning."
我们会解释说：“不，不，我们不是——这不是一个广播剧节目。这是‘剧场’，就像皮威·赫尔曼的那个‘剧场’，就像皮威·赫尔曼的那个‘剧场’。这是一个剧场。它是一个人们玩耍的地方，但它也是一个舞台。它有双重含义。”
It was when I decided that the name of this show should be "American" whatever that everyone who I work with decided not only was I wrong, but I was wrong in a profound way that indicated that we could never be friends. We could never truly understand or know each other. I was wrong in a way that was incomprehensible to the people who I work with every day.
那是我决定这个节目应该叫《美国》——无论那是什么——的时候，我共事的所有人都认为我不仅错了，而且错得很深，这预示着我们永远无法成为朋友。我们永远无法真正理解或了解彼此。我的错误方式让和我每天一起工作的人感到不可理喻。
I'm not here, however, to talk about myself and our little radio show because I believe that we accidentally stumbled onto a broader, more fundamental truth about naming something. Naming a business, a restaurant, a person, a dog. Well, not a dog really. Because people don't care what you name your dog. It's true of naming everything except for naming a dog.
然而，我来这里不是为了谈论我自己和我们的小广播节目，因为我相信我们偶然发现了一个关于命名事物的更广泛、更基本的真理。给企业、餐馆、人、狗起名。嗯，其实给狗起名不算。因为人们不在乎你给你的狗起什么名字。除了给狗起名，这适用于给一切事物命名。
People are unbelievably tolerant of naming a dog. You could name your dog "Your Radio Playhouse," and nobody would think twice about it. And I would send you a free coffee mug or something just for proving me right.
人们对给狗起名有着令人难以置信的宽容。你可以把你的狗命名为“你的无线电剧场”，没人会对此有二心。而且我会给你寄一个免费的咖啡杯或其他什么东西，只为了证明我是对的。
What I learned is that there's something about a name. Most creative acts that one does in one's life, there's enough content to them, they are longer than the length of a name. And so when people disagree with each other, they can discuss it. There's pros and cons. There are parts of it that you can dissect.
我学到的是，名字里有些名堂。人们一生中所做的创造性行为大多有足够的内容，它们比一个名字的长度要长。所以当人们有分歧时，他们可以讨论。有利有弊。有些部分是可以剖析的。
But a name is so basic. It's so undivideable, even if it's got a lot of words in it, that all you get is this visceral, very binary response. Like it. Don't like it.
但名字太基础了。它是不可分割的，即使它包含很多单词，你得到的只是这种本能的、非常二元的反应。喜欢它。不喜欢它。
Well, from WBEZ Chicago, this is Glass Works. See, I would need German music actually. From WBEZ Chicago, Glasnost. That's the most horrifying possibility is that you would end up using your own name. Well, we did settle on a new name.
好吧，来自芝加哥WBEZ电台，这是《格拉斯作品》。瞧，我其实需要德国音乐。来自芝加哥WBEZ电台，《开放政策》。最可怕的可能性就是你最终会使用你自己的名字。好吧，我们确实确定了一个新名字。
And by the way, we have a very unusual show tonight, many unusual things coming up.
顺便说一句，我们今晚有一个非常不寻常的节目，有很多不寻常的事情即将发生。
In Act Three, David Isaacson with the beginning of this new project where we're having various, very unusual writers and performers give their take on our presidential campaigns.
在第三幕中，大卫·艾萨克森将开启这个新项目，我们将让各种非常不寻常的作家和表演者对我们的总统竞选发表看法。
In Act Two, I don't even want to go into it. Just stay with us here because the show's going to change a lot.
在第二幕中，我甚至不想多说。请留在这里，因为节目会有很大的变化。
But anyway, we did settle on a new name. And to discuss the name and all the different names that led to the name, the pre-names, the discarded names, the-- oh, forget it. To discuss that, I called one of the grand old men of broadcasting. He's had the longest running talk show in the history of television. It's in New York. Joe Franklin.
但总之，我们确实确定了一个新名字。为了讨论这个名字以及导致这个名字的所有不同名字，那些预备名字、被废弃的名字，哦，算了吧。为了讨论那个，我打电话给广播界的一位老前辈。他在纽约主持着电视史上最长寿的脱口秀节目。乔·富兰克林。
[SOUND OF A TELEPHONE RINGING]
[电话铃声]
Hello?
喂？
Joe Franklin?
乔·富兰克林吗？
Yeah.
是我。
It's Ira Glass at the radio show in Chicago.
我是芝加哥广播节目的艾拉·格拉斯。
Right, Ira. Hold on for one second. Yeah, Jimmy? What color are they, Jimmy? Black? Give me 15 minutes, Jimmy. Yes, Ira?
对，艾拉。等我一下。喂，吉米？它们是什么颜色的，吉米？黑色的？给我15分钟，吉米。是的，艾拉？
What kind of business are you doing there?
你在那儿做什么生意？
Oh, Ira, I sell matzo balls.
哦，艾拉，我卖圆子。
And they're black?
它们是黑色的？
Codfish balls. No, a man lost his eyeglasses here. Yeah, what I gotta go through. What I gotta go through. And so what do you think of changing the name?
鳕鱼丸。不，有个人的眼镜丢在这儿了。是的，我得经历什么啊。我得经历什么啊。那么你觉得改名字怎么样？
Yeah, in fact, we've announced a name change. And you were on our first program, giving me advice about having a program which would have some longevity.
是的，事实上，我们已经宣布了更名。你曾参加过我们的第一个节目，给我建议，让我开办一个能长久的节目。
Yeah, yeah. We taped that in my office here, was it? Or in the studio?
对，对。我们在我办公室录的那个，是吗？还是在演播室？
We did it over the phone. So you were just sitting in your office, and you talked to me over the phone.
我们是在电话里完成的。所以你当时只是坐在你的办公室里，通过电话和我交谈。
I remember that, yeah.
我记得那个，没错。
And so we thought we'd have you back just to review some of these names.
所以我们想请你回来回顾一下这些名字。
I'm ready.
我准备好了。
OK, so let me run a couple of these titles by you. American Whatever.
好的，让我为你列举几个标题。《美国无论什么》。
American Whatever? Ambiguous, ambiguous.
《美国无论什么》？模棱两可，模棱两可。
Ira Glass and His Radio Cowboys.
《艾拉·格拉斯和他的无线电牛仔》。
Well, if you want to make a play on your name, I would call it The House of Glass. And let it be a hotel in the Catskills like Grossinger's, or Concord, or--
嗯，如果你想在你的名字上做文章，我会叫它《格拉斯之家》。让它像格罗辛格度假村、康科德度假村或者……
Brown's.
布朗度假村。
Or Brown's or a bungalow coloneer, what they call a kuchalane. But I would definitely call it, if you want to play on your name, The House of Glass.
或者布朗度假村，或者他们所谓的度假小屋。但如果你想在你的名字上做文章，我绝对会叫它《格拉斯之家》。
Actually, there were many suggestions especially from our Los Angeles affiliate. They were very strong on the idea of Glass House as the title.
其实有很多建议，特别是来自我们洛杉矶分部的人。他们非常支持以《格拉斯之家》作为标题。
Glass House, yeah. House of Glass is a little more erudite, a little more formal. But that's up to you.
《格拉斯之家》，是的。《格拉斯府邸》稍微博学一点，稍微正式一点。但这取决于你。
Other names that were suggested, Glasnost, which means "openness" because we're doing new stuff. Glass Menagerie. Splendor in the Glass. You don't seem impressed by any of these.
其他建议的名字有《开放政策》，意思是“公开”，因为我们在做新东西。《格拉斯动物园》。《光影浮华》。你似乎对这些都不感兴趣。
Keep off the Glass. Glass Has Class. No, those are good.
《格拉斯禁行》。《格拉斯有格调》。不，那些都不错。
OK, other titles. Radiolicious.
好的，其他标题。《电台美味》。
Vicious? Or licious?
恶毒？还是美味？
Licious.
美味。
Like "delicious?"
像“美味”那样？
Yes, sir.
是的，先生。
Too cutsy, too cutsy.
太矫情了，太矫情了。
A Million Stories.
《一百万个故事》。
Better than the preceding one, yeah, but still not great.
比上一个好，是的，但仍然不怎么样。
How about this title, This American Life?
这个标题怎么样，《这个美国生活》？
I would say that's about the best yet. Better than Your Radio Playhouse anyhow.
我会说这是目前为止最好的一个。反正比《你的无线电剧场》好。
I'm glad you say this because that's actually the one that we chose.
我很高兴你这么说，因为这其实就是我们选择的那个。
Yeah, yeah, yeah. That says it all. That says it all. No, I think anything we start with the word "America"-- the word "America" was the first word?
对，对，对。那说明了一切。那说明了一切。不，我认为任何以“美国”一词开头的——“美国”这个词是第一个词吗？
No, it's the second one actually. It's not the first one.
不，它其实是第二个词。它不是第一个。
Well, [UNINTELLIGIBLE] "America" near the beginning. Near the beginning is good.
好吧，在开头附近有“美国”。在开头附近很好。
As long as it's near the beginning.
只要它在开头附近。
Always, yeah.
总是这样，没错。
How important is a name?
名字有多重要？
I would say the name was everything. Look at Marilyn Monroe. Marilyn Monroe told me that the important thing in a name is to have a vowel sound, an ay, ee, eye, oh, or oo. Now what was that again? What was your title again? The American? Say it again.
我会说名字就是一切。看看玛丽莲·梦露。玛丽莲·梦露告诉我，名字里的重点是要有元音，ay, ee, eye, oh, 或 oo。那么刚才那个是什么来着？你的标题是什么来着？《美国人》？再说一遍。
This American Life.
《这个美国生活》。
At least you've got one. You've got the sound "eye," "life," "life." The name is everything.
至少你有一个。你有“eye”这个音，“life”，“life”。名字就是一切。
Well, wait. There's an I in "This."
等等。“This”里面有一个i。
But not the ay, eye, oh, oo sound. It's a soft I. It's got to be a hard I like the noun "eye." You know what I'm saying? There's got to be a sound of ay, ee, eye, oh, or you.
但不是ay, ee, eye, oh, 或 oo的声音。它是一个轻读的i。它必须是一个重读的i，像名词“eye”那样。你知道我在说什么吗？必须要有ay, ee, eye, oh, 或 oo的声音。像约翰·史密斯这样的名字没有重读元音，所以没那么吸引人。如果可以的话，名字里有元音总是可取的。
So wait, so what's a good title under this criterion?
等等，那么在这个标准下，什么是个好标题？
Well, no, This American Life. At least it ends on a vowel sound. It ends on a vowel.
嗯，不，《这个美国生活》。至少它以元音结尾。它以元音结尾。
Does The Joe Franklin Show conform to this rule?
《乔·富兰克林秀》符合这个规则吗？
Well, the word "Joe."
嗯，“Joe”这个词。
Oh, I see. It's a long vowel.
哦，我明白了。这是一个长元音。
"Joe" and "Show," yeah. "Tonight Show." "Late Show." You know what I'm saying? "Late." "To--" As long as it's got the ay, ee, eye, oh, or oo sound. A name like John Smith has got no hard vowel sound, and so it's not that appealing. It's always desirable to have vowels in your sounds if you can.
“Joe”和“Show”，对。“今夜秀”。“深夜秀”。你知道我在说什么吗？“Late”。“To--”只要它有ay, ee, eye, oh, 或 oo的声音。一个像约翰·史密斯的名字没有重读元音，所以它没那么有吸引力。如果可以的话，名字里有元音总是可取的。
TV talk show host Joe Franklin. He has a book out. He has nostalgic CDs everywhere.
电视脱口秀主持人乔·富兰克林。他出了一本书。他到处都有怀旧CD。
[MUSIC - "HEY, MR. DJ, I THOUGHT YOU SAID WE HAD A DEAL" BY THEY MIGHT BE GIANTS]
[音乐 - 巨人乐队的《嘿，电台主持人，我以为我们达成了协议》]
Act One, Pier Pressure. Well, last week on this program, as one of our stories about the state of the nation's economy, we did a report about Chicago's Navy Pier, what it cost taxpayers, and what they got out of it. It cost-- if you did not hear our show-- $155 million in taxpayers' money and created, at most, 1,200 jobs, about half of those part-time. That's $130,000 per job.
第一幕，《同辈压力》。上周在这个节目中，作为我们关于国家经济状况的故事之一，我们报道了芝加哥的海军码头，它让纳税人付出了什么，又从中得到了什么。如果你没听我们的节目，它花费了1.55亿美元的纳税人钱，最多创造了1200个就业岗位，其中约一半是兼职。平均每个岗位成本13万美元。
A spokesman for the city said that we should judge the pier by the pleasure that it gives Chicagoans and the overall boost that it gives to tourism, not by the cost per job created. But in our report, we also took pains to point out that, by all accounts, the pier has been a huge, huge business success. Crowds are twice as big as anyone projected. Over 3 million people in the first six months. The stores and restaurants on the pier say that they're doing well by and large.
一位市政府发言人表示，我们不应该以每个岗位创造的成本来评判码头，而应该以它给芝加哥人带来的快乐以及给旅游业带来的整体提升来评判。但在我们的报告中，我们也煞费苦心地指出，从各方面来看，码头的商业确实取得了巨大、巨大的成功。人群数量是任何人预测的两倍。前六个月超过300万人次。码头上的商店和餐馆表示，总体而言他们经营得不错。
But two days after our broadcast, the news broke that Navy Pier is, in fact, losing money, at least the city agency that runs the pier is. And they're losing a lot of money. $9 million in the pier's first eight months of business. Because of this, Navy Pier has announced that it will lay off one-fourth of its full-time staff and do other cost cutting.
但在我们广播两天后，新闻爆出海军码头实际上在亏钱，至少经营码头的市政机构是这样。而且他们损失惨重。码头营业的前八个月亏损了900万美元。正因为如此，海军码头宣布将裁掉四分之一的全职员工并削减其他开支。
We have put in several requests over the course of this week to speak with the head of the pier, James Reilly, or another pier spokesperson. We wanted to ask what was going wrong. How could they be doing such gangbuster business and still lose money? With over 3 million visitors, the city is losing $2 to $3 per visitor. And this at a place that charges $16 to park.
本周我们多次请求采访码头负责人詹姆斯·赖利或码头的其他发言人。我们想问哪里出了问题。他们怎么能在生意如此红火的情况下仍然亏损？拥有超过300万游客，城市却在每位游客身上损失2到3美元。而且这是一个停车费要16美元的地方。
All this week, the public relations office at Navy Pier has promised an interview. But in the end, this did not happen. The closest we can get to finding out why the pier is losing all this money is in Crain's Chicago Business. There, the head of the Pier Authority, Mr. Reilly, said the losses had to do with opening delays and what the paper called "first year inefficiencies." It did not go into details.
整个这周，海军码头的公关办公室都承诺接受采访。但最终，这并没有发生。我们能找到码头亏损原因的最接近的来源是《克莱恩芝加哥商业周刊》。在那里，码头管理局局长赖利先生说，亏损与开业延误以及报纸所称的“第一年效率低下”有关。他没有提供细节。
And we have one other amendment to last week's story on Navy Pier. When I came into work after the story aired, one of my fellow staffers here at Chicago's public radio station, this was Aaron Freeman, told me that in our coverage about the economics of Navy Pier, we had missed the main point of what makes the pier so worthwhile to Chicago taxpayers. And at the end of the workday, he loaded his two twin girls into their special wide-load double stroller. The radio station is located midway down Navy Pier. And we headed out into the promenade, so he could show me what he was talking about.
我们还要对上周关于海军码头的报道进行一项补充。报道播出后，当我来到芝加哥公共广播电台上班时，我的同事亚伦·弗里曼告诉我，我们在报道海军码头的经济效益时，忽略了它对芝加哥纳税人最有价值的核心意义。下班时，他把两个双胞胎女儿放进那辆特宽的双人婴儿车里。广播电台就位于海军码头的中段。我们走向滨海大道，他想向我展示他所说的内容。
If you're a parent, for families, this place is just the best place in the city of Chicago to bring your kids. Because no matter when you come down here, what time of day, your children will be amused.
如果你是家长，对于家庭来说，这里绝对是芝加哥最适合带孩子来的地方。因为无论你什么时候来，不管是一天中的什么时间，你的孩子都会玩得很开心。
So how often do you bring your kids here?
那你带孩子来这里的频率是多少？
They come here at least twice a week. I work down here, so I bring them down here at least twice a week. But I tell you, a lot of times, if I can't think of anything else to do, we come down here. And they just run around. They run around from store to store.
他们至少每周来两次。我在附近上班，所以至少带他们来两次。但我告诉你，很多时候如果我实在想不出做什么，我们就会来这里。他们就到处跑。他们从这家店跑到那家店。
It's colorful. They're four. So it's colorful. There's dolls. There's all kinds of fun colors.
这里色彩斑斓。他们才四岁，所以这些颜色很吸引人。有玩偶，各种各样有趣的颜色。
They love the Omnimax. They had the Serengeti show. And now they got the big 3D Omnimax. We haven't seen that yet.
他们喜欢奥尼马克巨幕电影。以前有塞伦盖蒂的节目。现在还有大型3D奥尼马克。我们还没看过那个。
There's bookstores you can go-- like The Children's Museum Shop. Even if The Children's Museum is closed, The Children's Museum gift shop, you can kill off half an hour, 45 minutes just looking at the stuff in there.
还有书店可以逛，比如儿童博物馆商店。即使儿童博物馆关门了，光是在礼品店里逛逛，你也能轻轻松松打发半小时到45分钟。
We headed to the atrium at the center of the pier. Aaron kept one hand on the stroller and threw the other in a broad sweep of the panorama.
我们走向码头中心的中庭。亚伦一只手扶着婴儿车，另一只手在空中画了一个大大的圆弧，展示着眼前的全景。
Now you look around, and there's nothing but great stuff. The Children's Museum. The Imax. The McDonald's. If you're a kid, you can't top this. There's toy stores. Just imagine. If you were a four-year-old, you look around here, is this not just a feast? If you're four. Just think back.
你看周围，到处都是好东西。儿童博物馆、IMAX、麦当劳。如果你是个孩子，这简直完美。这里有玩具店。想象一下，如果你是个四岁的孩子，环顾四周，这难道不是一场盛宴吗？如果你才四岁的话。回想一下吧。
It would be fun, sure.
确实会很有趣。
Well, OK, that's what I'm saying. Your parent, they are happy here. And there's stuff for parents to do in the museum. While the kid's running around enjoying all the primary colors, you can go drink, which is always a fun thing to do.
好吧，这就是我想说的。如果你是家长，孩子在这里很开心。博物馆里也有适合家长做的事。当孩子到处跑着欣赏那些原色时，你可以去喝一杯，这总是件愉快的事情。
We headed up to the Crystal Gardens, where, inside a big, glassed-in room, there are palm trees and jumping waters. Literally, streams of water which spurt out and jump from one artificial pond to another. As Aaron expounded on how wonderful all this was, I should note for the record that his two small children were not particularly enchanted. It was the end of the day. They were tired in a way that even $155 million of taxpayers' money cannot alter or change. As politicians like to say these days, there are some problems that government can't solve no matter how much money it throws at them. Diana slept, Artemis was cranky, jumping fountains or not.
我们前往水晶花园，在一个巨大的玻璃房里，种着棕榈树，还有跳跃的喷泉。确实，水流喷射出来，从一个人工池跳到另一个人工池。当亚伦滔滔不绝地讲述这一切有多美妙时，我必须记录下，他的两个小孩子并不觉得有多迷人。那天已经很晚了。她们疲惫不堪，这种疲惫感是1.55亿美元的纳税人资金也无法改变的。正如现在的政客们常说的那样，有些问题无论政府投入多少钱都无法解决。戴安娜睡着了，阿耳特弥斯则闹着脾气，管它什么跳跃喷泉。
I don't want to come here.
我不想来这里。
You don't want to be here? Where do you want to be?
你不想待在这儿？那你想到哪儿去？
Downstairs.
楼下。
Downstairs? All right.
楼下？好吧。
So we headed downstairs. When we got to the food court, Artemis perked up a bit.
于是我们下到了楼下。当我们到达美食广场时，阿耳特弥斯稍微振作了一点。
You have to get food, Dad.
爸爸，你得买吃的。
Yes, we have to get food. You want to have some pizza?
是的，我们得买吃的。你想吃披萨吗？
I'm going to get my own food.
我要自己买吃的。
What are you going to get? I thought you wanted pizza.
你要买什么？我还以为你想吃披萨。
I'm going to get oatmeal.
我要买燕麦粥。
Oatmeal?
燕麦粥？
Turns out oatmeal is not one of the fine dining options at the Navy Pier food court. Artemis hopped out of the stroller and headed over to Connie's Pizza.
结果发现海军码头美食广场的高级餐饮选项里并没有燕麦粥。阿耳特弥斯跳下婴儿车，走向康妮披萨店。
Oatmeal?
燕麦粥？
Huh?
嗯？
Do you have oatmeal?
你们有燕麦粥吗？
What'd you say?
你说什么？
Do you have oatmeal?
你们有燕麦粥吗？
Oh no, we don't have oatmeal here.
哦不，我们这儿没有燕麦粥。
Aaron ordered a pizza for the kids. And while we waited the two minutes that it takes to cook, his another daughter, Diana, made a little announcement.
亚伦为孩子们点了一份披萨。在我们等待制作那两分钟的过程中，他的另一个女儿戴安娜提出了一个小要求。
I need to show you something.
我需要给你们看个东西。
What do you need to show me? Well, I have to get food too though. OK?
你要给我看什么？不过我得先买吃的，好吗？
But I need to show you something.
但我需要给你们看个东西。
What do you want to show me?
你想给我看什么？
Well, it's really cool.
嗯，真的很酷。
Show me after we get food, OK?
等我们买完吃的再看，好吗？
Around us, it was pretty empty. No special events were taking place at the pier. But there were other families, kids run around, it was relaxed. Diana and Artemis goofed around, got into a tiny spat or two, then played some more. When the food arrived, Aaron had them do their regular family ritual, the blessings over the food.
我们周围比较空旷。码头上没有举行什么特别活动。但还有其他家庭，孩子们跑来跑去，气氛很放松。戴安娜和阿耳特弥斯嬉闹着，吵了一两次小架，然后又继续玩耍。食物到了，亚伦让她们按照常规家庭仪式，对食物进行感恩祷告。
Now is the crust made out of bread?
那面包皮是用面包做的吗？
Yes.
是的。
So what do we say?
那我们要说什么呢？
I know.
我知道。
[GIRLS SAYING THE JEWISH PRAYER OVER BREAD]
[女孩们在诵读关于面包的犹太祈祷文]
Amen.
阿门。
"What's it worth," Aaron asked me, "to have a place like this for families in the city. How do you want the city to spend taxpayers' money?" After they ate, another family ritual. The kids run each piece of trash to the garbage can, one piece at a time.
“拥有这样一个适合城市家庭的地方到底有多值？”亚伦问我，“你希望这座城市如何花费纳税人的钱？”吃完后，又是另一个家庭仪式。孩子们把每一件垃圾送到垃圾桶，一次只拿一件。
Daddy.
爸爸。
Are you having fun?
玩得开心吗？
No.
不。
Good. OK, here you go. You seem to be nervous about the 20 feet, 25 feet over to the trash. Now you see, there's a closer trash can, but they like running. They're young. They haven't learned about this conservation of energy thing.
好吧。好了，给你。你好像对走到20到25英尺外的垃圾桶很紧张。你看，其实有个更近的垃圾桶，但她们喜欢跑。她们还小，还没学会什么叫节能。
What else?
还有吗？
There you go.
给你。
By the time he puts them in the car, Aaron says, they'll be exhausted, ready to go to sleep, down for the night. What parent is going to complain about that? After the trash is thrown away, Aaron wants to buy them ice cream, but Diana remembers there's one bit of unfinished business.
亚伦说，等他把她们送进车里，她们就会精疲力尽，准备入睡，熬过这一晚。哪个家长会抱怨这个呢？垃圾扔掉后，亚伦想给她们买冰淇淋，但戴安娜想起还有一件未完成的事。
And then you guys could go with me to see the surprise?
然后你们可以跟我一起去看那个惊喜吗？
What is the surprise?
惊喜是什么？
If I told you, it won't be a surprise, silly.
如果我告诉你，那就不叫惊喜了，傻瓜。
So we gather our things, and we follow Diana to the surprise. We had passed the food court and through the McDonald's, which has a special space age decor with lots of lights and colors.
于是我们收拾好东西，跟着戴安娜去看惊喜。我们经过了美食广场，穿过了麦当劳，那里有着充满未来感的装饰，灯光和色彩非常丰富。
Dad says that all of these things are not the surprises.
爸爸说这些东西都不是惊喜。
We're not there.
还没到呢。
Diana spins around.
戴安娜转了个圈。
Hey, where did I see it? It was here somewhere. It was here somewhere.
嘿，我在哪儿看到的？肯定是在这儿。就在这儿。
Diana runs in that rapid waddle very small children have when they run, through the McDonald's, unable to find her original surprise, when, suddenly, she hears music coming from the hall and waddle-runs toward it pointing.
戴安娜用幼童那种特有的快速摇摆步子跑过麦当劳，找不到她原本预想的惊喜。突然，她听到大厅传来的音乐，便指着那个方向跑去。
Oh, look! A parade! That's the surprise I was looking for! There, look!
哦，看！有游行！这就是我在找的惊喜！在那儿，看！
It's not a parade, but Pier Pressure, four jazz musicians hired by the pier, playing in an otherwise empty atrium.
那不是游行，是“码头压力”乐队，四名由码头聘请的爵士乐手正在空旷的中庭演奏。
I see a parade! Look! That's cool! Look!
我看到游行了！看！真酷！看！
She stands there pointing at the band excitedly, turning to look up at her dad, turning back to the band. It's tempting to call this a priceless moment. But of course, we know the price. $155 million, plus the $12 that Aaron's spending on food and treats, plus parking. The girls listen happily to the music for a while and then head out for ice cream and the car ride home.
她兴奋地站在那里指着乐队，转头看着爸爸，又转头看向乐队。人们很容易称这一刻为“无价之宝”。但当然，我们知道价格。1.55亿美元，外加亚伦在食物和零食上花的12美元，还有停车费。女孩们开心地听了一会儿音乐，然后去买冰淇淋，开车回家。
Come on, buddy.
走吧，伙计。
Act Two, Fan Dance. You've probably already seen the footage. There's the courtroom with that grainy, ugly lighting that courtrooms have on TV. There's the judge. There's the usual assortment of disheveled looking men and women in suits who do the business of all courtrooms, lawyers, the jurors, the press, the audience. And there, among them, a woman in a Star Trek uniform.
第二幕，扇子舞。你们可能已经看过那个片段了。那是法庭，有着电视里法庭那种粗颗粒、难看的灯光。那是法官。那是法庭里常见的那种穿着西装、看起来有些邋遢的人——律师、陪审员、媒体、旁听席。而在他们中间，有一个穿着星际迷航制服的女人。
This was the Whitewater trial. And the woman in the uniform was on the jury, Barbara Adams is her name. She has since been removed from the jury, and people have snickered all across the country. But one of the most interesting discussions of this juror and of what we are to make of her occurred on the internet, on something called a list serve group, this one about fandom. This is fandom, as in fans of TV shows, especially science fiction shows, like Babylon 5, Star Trek, that kind of thing.
这是怀特沃特事件的审判。穿着制服的女人是陪审团成员，她叫芭芭拉·亚当斯。后来她被从陪审团中除名，全国各地的人都为此窃窃私语。但关于这位陪审员以及我们该如何看待她的最有趣的讨论之一，出现在互联网上，在一个名为“列表服务组”的群组里，这个群组是关于“粉丝文化”的。这是指电视节目的粉丝，特别是科幻节目，比如《巴比伦5号》、《星际迷航》之类的。
This group is devoted to the academic study of what it means to be a fan. And on it are fans and academics who post messages to each other. And the discussion kicked off with one woman who wrote in in disbelief.
这个群体致力于学术研究“粉丝”的意义。成员包括粉丝和学者，他们互相发布消息。讨论是由一位女士发起的，她写道，表示难以置信。
"I only saw a brief bit of it on CNN, but it immediately made me want to go and hide somewhere. There was footage of the juror in ST:TNG uniform--" Star Trek, The Next Generation-- "complete with phaser and assorted gear, I believe. And upon seeing the bank of news cameras, this juror gave them the Vulcan salute. Am I getting this correctly? Can anybody fill in some of the blanks? Am I wrong for being embarrassed for Trek fandom in general? I mean, as far as providing a handy, digestible image for vast tracts of cable-watching America of the fan as crazed, detached from reality, lunatic nerd, that picture seemed worth a thousand words. Anybody else even see this? Or have I been breathing too many photocopy fumes again?"
“我只在CNN上看了简短片段，但它立刻让我想要找个地方躲起来。片段里有那位穿着《星际迷航：下一代》制服的陪审员——配有相位枪和各种装备。看到一排排新闻摄像机，这位陪审员还向他们行了瓦肯举手礼。我没看错吧？有人能填补一下背景信息吗？因为《星际迷航》的粉丝群体感到尴尬是我不对吗？我的意思是，对于那些观看有线电视的美国大众来说，这提供了一个现成的、易于消化的形象，即粉丝是疯狂的、脱离现实的、神经质的书呆子，这张照片真可谓胜过千言万语。还有人看到这个了吗？还是我又吸入了太多复印机废气？”
What's so interesting is her horror. She was horrified in the way that you're horrified when you see a member of your own family do something strange in public. Other people wrote in and reassured her that, yes, this was real. Here's one.
最有趣的是她的那种惊恐。那是一种当你看到自己的家人在公共场合做出奇怪举动时感到的那种惊恐。其他人写信安慰她，是的，这是真的。这里有一条：
"The woman did come fully dressed with phaser as an alternate juror. The first day, the pictures showed her as a curiosity. And a day or two later, however, the journalists could not resist asking her what it was all about. She said very politely that she was the commander of a local starship, a Star Trek group in Little Rock, that she wore her uniform to all formal occasions to remind the general public of the meaning of Star Trek.
“作为候补陪审员，她确实全副武装并带着相位枪出席了。第一天，照片显示她是个稀奇人物。然而一两天后，记者们无法抗拒地问她是怎么回事。她非常有礼貌地说，她是小石城一个星际迷航小组的指挥官，她在所有正式场合都穿制服，是为了提醒公众《星际迷航》的意义。”
I think the reporters were probably laughing at first. But then the last article I read said that she was an excellent juror, very serious, took copious notes. The reason she was dismissed was that the reporters had asked her outside the courthouse about the uniform. And although there was a gag order on the trial, she felt it was OK to talk since Star Trek had nothing to do with the trial. She only gave them a short, polite answer, so, she said, they'd leave her alone. The judge says that she'd violated the gag order and dismissed her. The article seemed to indicate that she got a bum deal."
“我想记者们起初可能是在嘲笑她。但后来我读到的最后一篇文章说，她是一位优秀的陪审员，非常严肃，做了大量的记录。她被解雇的原因是记者在法庭外询问了她的制服。尽管审判有封口令，但她觉得既然《星际迷航》与审判无关，谈论一下也没关系。她只给了他们简短、礼貌的回答，以便让他们别来烦她。法官说她违反了封口令，便解雇了她。那篇文章似乎暗示她遭受了不公正的对待。”
I had mixed feelings reading about it. I once had a student in a group Comm class I was teaching do the exact same thing. Every class, he showed up in his uniform. At first, people sniggered. But he was very polite. And the uniform gave him self-confidence, I think.
读到这些时，我的感受很复杂。我曾在一门我教的小组交流课上遇到过一个学生做了完全一样的事。每一节课，他都穿着制服出现。起初，大家窃窃私语。但他非常有礼貌。而且我认为，制服给了他自信。
Eventually, everyone in class accepted it, as much as they accepted African-American and religious symbols, and they even used him as an expert on a mock group exercise. They had to figure out in a group process how to equip a spaceship for a long journey.
最终，班上的每个人都接受了他，就像他们接受非裔美国人和宗教符号一样，他们甚至在一次模拟小组练习中把他当作专家。他们必须在小组流程中弄清楚如何为长途旅行装备一艘宇宙飞船。
People started to weigh in, saying that no, they should not be embarrassed at all as Star Trek fans. One wrote, "Embarrassed for Trek fandom? I was proud of the uniform-clad, Whitewater would-be juror." "She said she always wears her uniform to formal events. Frankly, I'd rather be associated with Trekkers than with the Governor of Arkansas or any of the garbage that apparently goes down in Little Rock. The juror looked a lot less stupid than two-thirds of the past and present Clinton administrations."
人们开始发表意见，说不，作为《星际迷航》的粉丝根本不应该感到尴尬。有人写道：“为星际迷航粉丝感到尴尬？我为那位身穿制服、差一点成为怀特沃特案陪审员的人感到骄傲。她说她总是穿着制服参加正式活动。坦率地说，我宁愿与星际迷航迷为伍，也不愿与阿肯色州州长或小石城发生的那些烂事为伍。这位陪审员看起来比克林顿政府过去和现在的三分之二的人要聪明得多。”
And a man named Henry Jenkins posted a note to the group. He is the director of film and media studies at MIT and author of two books about fandom. The latest is called Science Fiction Audiences, Watching Star Trek and Doctor Who. He says that as someone who's been a fan for 20 years, he's often thought there are strong analogies between the way that gays and lesbians deal with these kinds of issues and the way the fan community does.
一个名叫亨利·詹金斯的人给小组写了一张便条。他是麻省理工学院电影与媒体研究主任，著有两本关于粉丝文化的书。最新的一本叫《科幻观众，观看星际迷航和神秘博士》。他说，作为一名有20年经验的粉丝，他经常认为同性恋者处理这类问题的方式与粉丝群体处理的方式之间存在强烈的相似之处。
He talked about the politics of cultural preference, people who feel strong attachment to certain things in the culture, as being similar to the politics of sexual preference. We asked him if he'd go into a radio studio in Boston and read some of his posting for us. And he was gracious enough to agree.
他谈到了文化偏好的政治，即人们对文化中某些事物有强烈的依恋，这与性取向的政治相似。我们邀请他到波士顿的广播电台录音室，为我们读了一些他的帖子。他非常大度地答应了。
I've often thought there are strong analogies to be drawn between the queer community's politics of sexual preference and the fan community's politics of cultural preference. From the point of view of mundane culture, both groups provoke discomfort concerning their scandalous taste and shocking behavior. One often hears people speak of "coming out" as a fan or "being closeted" at work. Fans often hide their cultural preferences, afraid of what their office mates might think about their hobbies, their friends, their creative accomplishments, or how they spend their weekends. I've known many fans who've had to hide fanzines from unsympathetic eyes or lie to their spouses about going to a convention.
我常认为，酷儿群体的性取向政治与粉丝群体的文化偏好政治之间存在着强烈的类比关系。从世俗文化的视角来看，这两个群体都因其“令人不齿”的品味和“惊世骇俗”的行为而引发不安。人们常听到粉丝说要“出柜”，或是形容自己在工作中“处于隐身状态”。粉丝们往往会隐藏自己的文化偏好，害怕同事们会对他们的爱好、朋友、创意成果或周末的安排产生看法。我认识许多粉丝，他们不得不把粉丝杂志藏起来，以免被不理解的人看到，或是为了去参加展会而对配偶撒谎。
And most of us have been snickered at and subjected to endless harangues in the popular media. We have our own terminological disputes, rejecting the outsider term "Trekkie," with its historic ties to groupie, for the insider term "Trekker," with its positive connotations of active participation. That's why many of us automatically cringed when we saw pictures of the Whitewater juror in her Starfleet uniform.
我们大多数人都曾在媒体上被冷嘲热讽，并遭受过无休止的抨击。我们内部也有术语之争，比如拒绝使用带有“追星族”这种历史负面含义的外来词“Trekkie”（星际迷航迷），而改用带有积极参与含义的内部词汇“Trekker”。正因如此，当我们在新闻中看到“白水案”陪审员穿着星际舰队制服的照片时，许多人会不自觉地感到尴尬。
But in his posting on the internet, Jenkins wrote that he rethought this position when he thought about his analogy to queer politics.
但在互联网上的一篇帖子中，詹金斯写道，当他想到自己关于酷儿政治的类比时，他重新思考了这个立场。
It seems to me that an awful lot of what we do in the fan community has strong parallels with some of the debates that occur in the communities surrounding gays and lesbians. There's a debate going on there right now that's often labeled "the place at the table debate" because it grows out of Bruce Bowers' book A Place at the Table. The central issue is, on the gay community, on the one hand, Bower is arguing that gays should assimilate, that they should downplay transgressive behaviors.
在我看来，粉丝社区中很多做法与同性恋群体周遭发生的讨论有着强烈的相似之处。目前那里正在进行一场通常被称为“餐桌一席之地之争”的辩论，它源于布鲁斯·鲍尔的书《餐桌一席之地》。核心问题在于，一方面，鲍尔主张同性恋者应该同化，应该淡化那些越轨行为。
That they should mainstream themselves, that they should try to appear like other people.
他们应该融入主流，应该努力表现得像普通人一样。
They should  mainstream themselves. Exactly. They shouldn't be parading around in drag, or in leather on Gay Pride parades, and so forth. That they should try to fit in, and then they might gain acceptance that way.
他们应该融入主流。没错。他们不应该在同性恋骄傲游行中穿着变装或皮衣招摇过市，诸如此类。他们应该努力融入，通过这种方式获得接纳。
The problem, of course, is that that pushes the queer community into doing the dirty work for the family values folks. You seek acceptance by policing your own ranks and by saying what's normal and what's not. And the argument goes that one's only free as a community when even the most extreme behavior is allowed to express itself. And I think if we read the fan's behavior by those standards, that is, as an expression of her cultural preferences, then we have to defend her right to wear the uniform and respect the courage in confronting the public ridicule that surrounded her action.
当然，问题在于这会迫使酷儿群体为推崇家庭价值观的人做脏活。你通过监管自己的队伍、界定什么是正常什么是不正常来寻求接纳。而辩论的观点是，只有当即使是最极端的行为也能被允许表达时，作为一个群体才是真正的自由。我认为，如果我们用这些标准来解读那位粉丝的行为，即将其视为她文化偏好的表达，那么我们必须捍卫她穿制服的权利，并尊重她面对围绕其行为的公众嘲讽时所展现出的勇气。
Her choice represents a new kind of fan identity politics, as you would, that we're tired of being told by William Shatner and others to get a life. We're tired of being stereotyped as living in our parents' basement. In fact, we are a wide variety of people who happen to believe in the cultural power of television and of all art to change the way we think about the universe.
她的选择代表了一种新型的粉丝身份政治，可以说，我们厌倦了被威廉·夏特纳和其他人告知“去过正常生活吧”。我们厌倦了被刻板地认为只会住在父母的地下室里。事实上，我们是一群广泛的人，我们恰好相信电视和所有艺术具有改变我们思考宇宙方式的文化力量。
So what's exciting about the fan's behavior is that she wasn't afraid. She didn't hide. She asserted very publicly who she was and what her commitments were. And I see it as striking a blow for the dignity of fans, particularly given how thoughtful, moderate, and articulate she happened to be.
所以，这位粉丝的行为令人兴奋之处在于她并不害怕。她没有隐藏，而是非常公开地宣称了她是谁以及她的承诺所在。我认为这为粉丝的尊严赢得了尊重，特别是考虑到她表现得如此理智、温和且条理清晰。
Did you cringe a little bit when you saw her?
当你看到她时，你有没有感到一点点尴尬？
When I first saw it, I did. But as I started to think through this issue, I started to think, "Why am I cringing? Why am I ashamed?" I've written two books on Star Trek fan culture. I have a very strong commitment to the idea that it is one of the important participatory cultures of our time, that it is one way people have of talking back to television, of taking control of their own lives, and creating their own culture from the materials they borrow from the mass media. So I shouldn't be ashamed, in fact, to see it projected even in the most public and political of spaces.
我刚看到时确实有。但当我开始深入思考这个问题时，我反问自己：“我为什么尴尬？我为什么要感到羞耻？”我写过两本关于《星际迷航》粉丝文化的书。我坚定地认为，这是我们这个时代重要的参与式文化之一，是人们对电视进行回馈、掌控自己生活，并利用从大众媒体借来的素材创造属于自己文化的一种方式。所以，即使在最公开和政治化的空间里看到它，我其实也不应该感到羞耻。
What does it mean to be a fan?
成为一名粉丝意味着什么？
Well, I think increasingly it means what it is to be an American in this digital age, that is, if we look at-- Harris tells us that more than 53% of the American public consider themselves to be Star Trek fans. That means an awful lot of those are not people who wear rubber Spock ears and overly tight velour uniforms, that they are people who represent the full range of American life. And as we begin to move online as a society, it seems abundantly clear that television fandom becomes a central motivation that gets people to participate in the digital realm, that is, what are we going to talk about when we go online and have the possibility of talking to people from around the country and around the world?
嗯，我认为它越来越意味着在这个数字时代做一个美国人是什么意思。也就是说，如果我们看——哈里斯告诉我们，超过53%的美国公众认为自己是《星际迷航》的粉丝。这意味着其中绝大多数人并不是戴着橡胶史波克耳朵、穿着过紧丝绒制服的人，他们是代表了美国生活方方面面的人。随着我们社会开始转向线上，电视迷文化显然成了促使人们参与数字领域的核心动力。也就是说，当我们上网并有机会与全国乃至全球的人交流时，我们要谈论什么呢？
We're not going to talk about my aunt Agatha who you and the people in Chicago have never heard of before. We're going to talk about people, and images, and stories that we share in common. And those images, in all likelihood, are going to come from national or even internationally circulated shows like Star Trek. So the point is that national media provides the fan community with a way of telling its own stories, of framing its own identities which allows it to speak to each other across all kinds of isolation we face as a society.
我们不会谈论你和芝加哥人从来没听说过的我的阿姨阿加莎。我们会谈论我们共同拥有的那些人、图像和故事。而这些图像，很有可能来自像《星际迷航》这样在国内甚至国际上广为流传的节目。所以关键点在于，国家媒体为粉丝社区提供了一种讲述自身故事、构建自身身份的方式，这使得我们能够跨越社会中各种各样的隔阂与彼此交流。
Henry Jenkins is director of film and media studies at MIT. He spoke with us from WBUR in Boston. And we close our virtual visit with him with one last reading from his internet posting.
亨利·詹金斯是麻省理工学院电影与媒体研究系主任。他从波士顿的WBUR电台与我们通话。我们通过阅读他互联网帖子中的最后一段来结束对他的虚拟访问。
Now the most interesting aspect of the story is not that she wore her uniform to the court, but that she got selected despite, or perhaps even because, she wore the uniform. Jury selection in a high-profile case like Whitewater has become an increasingly exact science. Experts make recommendations to lawyers based on a body of stereotypes about how different social groups are likely to respond to certain kinds of cases or arguments. Blacks are good for the defense, white men are good for the prosecution, and so forth.
现在这个故事最有趣的一点不是她穿制服去法庭，而是尽管她穿了制服，或者可能正是因为她穿了制服，她才被选中。在像“白水案”这种备受瞩目的案件中，陪审员的选择已成为一门日益精准的科学。专家根据各种社会群体对特定案件或论点的反应倾向的刻板印象，向律师提出建议。黑人有利于辩方，白人男性有利于检方，诸如此类。
But there probably never needed to be a grid for fans as a social group before. So what stereotypes of fans did the experts draw upon in assessing this particular juror? When I first saw her picture in the paper, as she was awaiting jury selection, my immediate response was that she'd never get picked. Neither the prosecution nor the defense would find her acceptable because, as a Trekker, she would be seen as too aberrant, too unpredictable, too abnormal and excessive. Instead, I suspect a different stereotype clicked into place, the notion that fans are gullible, easily led, easily manipulated. Both sets of lawyers probably thought that they could control her with their rhetoric. After all, if she can't tell the difference between a TV show and real life, she's a pushover for whatever arguments they wanted to make.
但在那之前，可能从未有人为“粉丝”这个社会群体建立过这样的网格。那么，专家在评估这位特殊的陪审员时，运用了哪些关于粉丝的刻板印象呢？我第一次在报纸上看到她在等待陪审员筛选时的照片时，我的第一反应是她绝不会被选中。无论是控方还是辩方都不会觉得她可以接受，因为作为一个“Trekker”，她会被视为太离经叛道、太不可预测、太不正常且过度。相反，我怀疑是另一种刻板印象起了作用：认为粉丝容易轻信、容易被引导、容易被操纵。两边的律师可能都认为可以用他们的修辞来控制她。毕竟，如果她分不清电视节目和现实生活，那么对于他们想要提出的任何论点，她都是一个软柿子。
The woman we saw interviewed on television news, however, fits neither stereotype. She was thoughtful, moderate, and articulate. She also happens to be a Star Trek fan. Get used to it. The whole case is, as Mr. Spock would say, fascinating.
然而，我们在电视新闻中采访看到的这位女性，并不符合上述任何一种刻板印象。她理智、温和且条理清晰。她同时也恰好是《星际迷航》的粉丝。习惯就好。正如史波克先生所说，整个案件非常“迷人”。
Well, we move on to another kind of fandom when our program continues.
好了，节目继续，我们来看看另一种粉丝文化。
It's This American Life. I'm Ira Glass. Act Two continues. So let's say it's not Star Trek that shapes your identity. Let's say it's G.I. Joe.
这是《美国生活》。我是艾拉·格拉斯。第二幕继续。假设塑造你身份的不是《星际迷航》。假设是特种部队（G.I. Joe）。
When Cindy Patton was nine, after lots of hinting around to her family, she was given a G.I. Joe Christmas. Next to her collection of incredibly detailed Matchbox cars, it was her favorite toy. But after three idyllic years with G.I. Joe, her mother started to get worried about certain tendencies she was noticing in Cindy. And at Christmas, Cindy only got clothes, only dresses in fact.
辛迪·巴顿九岁时，在向家人暗示了很久之后，她收到了一个特种部队玩具作为圣诞礼物。除了她那套极其精致的火柴盒小汽车收藏外，这是她最喜欢的玩具。但在与特种部队共度了三年的田园诗般的时光后，她母亲开始担心辛迪身上表现出的一些倾向。到了圣诞节，辛迪只收到了衣服，准确地说是裙子。
My mother and my sister, at one point, looked at me. And my mother said in this tone that now seems-- I can just hear it. "This year, we're going to make you into a little lady." But my response at the time-- I was a very calculating little child-- my response at the time was, "I can outlast this." And I figured about six more years and I would be off to college, and then I could do whatever I wanted.
有一次，我母亲和姐姐看着我。我母亲用那种——现在听起来——我依然记忆犹新的语调说：“今年，我们要把你变成一个小淑女。”但我当时的反应——我是一个非常有心计的小孩——我当时的反应是：“我可以熬过这一关。”我想大概再过六年我就能上大学了，到那时我就能做任何我想做的事。
In college, Cindy came out as gay. Now she's a professor at Temple University, writes a lot about gay issues. But at some point in her mid-20s, she became sort of obsessed with getting her favorite toys back from her parents.
在大学里，辛迪公开了自己的同性恋身份。现在她是天普大学的教授，撰写了大量关于同性恋议题的文章。但在她25岁左右的某个时候，她开始有点执迷于从父母那里拿回她最喜欢的玩具。
I describe it as this quest to get them back because my parents kept, on varying pretexts, preventing me from taking these toys. Now I had taken a few other stuffed animals and things like that. So it wasn't like they were trying to prevent me from taking toys in general. But these particular toys seemed to be unable to leave my parents' home.
我把这描述为一场拿回它们的任务，因为我父母以各种借口阻止我带走这些玩具。我确实带走了一些其他的毛绒玩具之类的东西。所以并不是说他们试图阻止我拿走所有玩具。但这些特定的玩具似乎就是无法离开我父母的家。
I flew down at one point. And that time, I think, my mother said, "Oh, the planes are really crowded, and you can only take so many things on. And so you can't take these toys. We'll come visit you and bring them." And of course, when they came to visit, they had forgotten to bring them. And this went on for several years. And I finally sent this very no-ifs-ands-or-buts letter, basically saying, "Send me my toys."
有一次我飞过去。那次我妈说：“哦，飞机太挤了，你带不了那么多东西。所以你不能带这些玩具。我们会去看你，然后带给你。”当然，当他们来访时，他们忘了带。这种情况持续了好几年。最终我写了一封不容置疑的信，基本上就是说：“把我的玩具寄给我。”
My nephews were given various toys of mine to play with. And they were not very careful. And so I'd become alarmed, and I felt intruded upon or betrayed in some way by having these toys of mine given to my nephews. It was, of course, under the guise of, "Your sister doesn't have very much money. And you have these toys. They might as well get used."
我的侄子们得到了我的各种玩具来玩。他们不太爱惜。所以我变得很焦虑，我觉得自己的东西被侵犯了，或者因为我的玩具被给了侄子们而感到背叛。当然，这是以“你姐姐没多少钱，而你有这些玩具，不如让它们发挥作用”为借口的。
But I think it was also about-- or at least in my mind anyway, there was something about the toys finding their way into the appropriate gender's hands. That somehow, as a girl child, that I had not used these toys in the appropriate way or something, that there had been something wrong about my relation to them that would be recuperated by them having boy children having them, and using them, and playing with them.
但我认为这还关乎——或者至少在我脑海里是这样——关于这些玩具被送到了“性别合适”的孩子手里。某种程度上，作为女孩，我没有以“正确”的方式使用这些玩具，或者诸如此类，我和它们的关系有些“不对劲”，而通过让男孩们拥有、使用和玩耍它们，这种关系就能得到“修复”。
At some point, Cindy Patton noticed how urgently she wanted those toys back from her parents. And she started to remember things about the toys that she had forgotten, how she'd cared for them meticulously, always returning G.I. Joe to his box after playing with him, keeping track of every accessory, every instruction sheet. Her Matchbox cars were like new after years of playing with them. The doors still worked, steering wheels still turned.
在某个时刻，辛迪·巴顿注意到她从父母那里拿回这些玩具的愿望是多么迫切。她开始回想起关于这些玩具的一些她已经遗忘的事情：她是如何精心呵护它们的，玩完后总是把特种部队放回盒子里，记录每一个配件、每一张说明书。她的火柴盒小汽车玩了几年后依然像新的一样。车门还能开，方向盘还能转。
I think in a way, though I keep calling it obsessive compulsive, it's less about some sort of obsessive compulsive desire than it is about a kind of ritual of preservation. I wonder whether when I was a kid, I realized that I wasn't going to get away with this, this not really being a girl. And so that I was very, very careful to keep very, very good care of these particular toys. I generally took good care of my toys, but I was especially detailed in taking care of these toys. It was almost like a kind of meditation. The toys themselves and this particular obsession I had for retrieving them from my family really made me recognize the complexity of my own gender structure and probably gender structures in general.
我想在某种程度上，虽然我一直称之为强迫症，但与其说这是一种强迫性的欲望，不如说这是一种“保存的仪式”。我想知道，当我是个孩子时，我是否意识到我无法瞒天过海，也就是我并不是真的女孩。所以我非常、非常小心地照顾这些特定的玩具。我通常都会照顾好我的玩具，但我对这些玩具特别细致。这几乎就像一种冥想。这些玩具本身以及我试图从家里找回它们的执念，让我真正认识到了我自身性别结构的复杂性，也可能认识到了性别结构本身的复杂性。
What she realized was that she wanted this part of her past that was "boy," where she was like a boy. And the reason why this was such a revelation was that she was of the generation of lesbians who came of age in the 1970s. The so-called lesbian feminists, who wanted to do away with the old lesbian order in which some women were more butch, more like men, and some were femme, more like women. They wanted to move towards a neutral non-gender.
她意识到的是，她想要保留她过去那一部分“男孩”的经历，那时她就像个男孩。之所以这成了一个巨大的启示，是因为她是20世纪70年代成长起来的那一代女同性恋者。所谓的“女权主义女同性恋”，她们想要废除旧的同性恋秩序——即一些女性更男性化（Butch），一些更女性化（Femme）。她们想要走向一种中性的、无性别的状态。
This idea is actually out of fashion now among younger lesbians. Butch and femme are back and back with a vengeance. But seeing then how much she wanted G.I. Joe, her old G.I. Joe, and her Matchbox cars was what made Cindy Patton realize she thought that she wasn't this neutral, non-gender person. She realized that she thought of herself more as a boy. Finally, the package came.
这个想法在现在的年轻女同性恋者中已经过时了。男性化和女性化风格又回来了，而且卷土重来。但看到当时她是多么渴望特种部队——她旧时的特种部队，还有她的火柴盒小汽车——让辛迪·巴顿意识到，她认为自己并不是那种中性的、无性别的人。她意识到自己更倾向于把自己看作一个男孩。终于，包裹寄到了。
I was in shock. I couldn't believe that it had finally come. My heart was beating. And I think I was driving to work or something, and I picked them up at the post office on the way. And I think I might have waited until lunch and then gone back out to the car, and surreptitiously opened the package, and found these things in it. I was quite moved. It was like recovering a piece of my childhood or my childhood as a boy.
我当时惊呆了。我简直不敢相信它终于到了。我的心跳加速。我想我当时正开车去上班，在路上顺便在邮局取了包裹。我可能一直等到午饭时间，才回到车里，偷偷摸摸地打开包裹，发现了里面的东西。我很感动。就像找回了我童年的一部分，或者说找回了我作为男孩的童年。
Act Three, Fan, Not Fan. We begin a little radio experiment today on our program to have non-journalists cover aspects of the presidential campaign, commission original work from these non-journalists. We begin with Chicago playwright David Isaacson, whose done many plays here in Chicago for Theater Oobleck. He prepared this about Pat Buchanan.
第三幕，粉丝，非粉丝。今天我们的节目开始了一个小小的广播实验，让非专业记者报道总统竞选活动的某些方面，并委托这些非专业人士创作原创作品。我们从芝加哥剧作家大卫·艾萨克森开始，他在芝加哥为Oobleck剧院创作过许多戏剧。他准备了这段关于帕特·布坎南的内容。
I had a dream last night, which is an odd thing in and of itself because I am not prone to dreaming especially lately, exhausted after very full days campaigning, Galesburg, Peoria, South Side Chicago. Why don't I dream at night? Well, Herr Sigismund Freud and his cabal of Austrio-atheist mind doctors say that dreams are the nocturnal expressions of all that is repressed during the day. But the thing is I don't repress. If it pops into my head, I let it pop right out of my mouth. That's the source of my pop, pop, popularity.
昨晚我做了一个梦，这本身就很奇怪，因为我不容易做梦，尤其是最近，每天竞选活动结束后我都精疲力竭，去过盖尔斯堡、皮奥里亚、芝加哥南区。为什么我晚上不做梦？嗯，西格蒙德·弗洛伊德先生和他的奥地利无神论心理医生帮派说，梦是白天被压抑的一切事物的夜间表达。但问题是我不压抑。如果它跳进我的脑海，我就让它从嘴里跳出来。这就是我人气“爆棚”的来源。
While the Clintons and Doles check the contingencies and polls before every public utterance, I'm utterly straight with my public. I don't repress, so I don't dream. Except last night. It was the oddest thing. I dreamt of myself, but myself in the past, and in the present, and in the future.
当克林顿和多尔在每次公开讲话前都要权衡各种应急情况和民意调查时，我对我的公众完全坦诚。我不压抑，所以我也不做梦。除了昨晚。那是最奇怪的事情。我梦到了我自己，但不是现在的我，而是过去的我、现在的我以及未来的我。
The first part, it was very green. Green grass everywhere, green grasses, rushes, and ferns. Puffins flying overhead. Druids leaned against dolmens, fashioning wreaths of mistletoe. I stood in front of an enormous electrified chain-link fence that went on and on, disappearing into the cloud-filled horizons both north and south. Apparently, I was the border guard in ancient Celtic Ireland.
第一部分，到处都很绿。到处都是绿草、绿草地、灯心草和蕨类植物。海鹦在头顶飞过。德鲁伊教徒倚靠在支石墓上，编织着槲寄生花环。我站在一道巨大的通电铁丝网围栏前，它延伸得很远，消失在南北方充满云层的地平线上。显然，我是古代凯尔特爱尔兰的边境守卫。
And lo, who should appear on the other side of this mass of barbed wire and steel, but my namesake, Saint Patrick. "Saint Patrick," I cried out. "Well, this is a fine how-do-you do. They were just booing me at your parade in Chicago the other day, hissing and--" And then old Saint Patrick interrupted me. "I have come to be the bishop of your land." "Well, I don't know, Saint," I replied. "Where were you born?" "Britain. In Britain."
瞧，在这一大堆铁丝网和钢材的另一边出现的不是别人，正是与我同名的圣帕特里克。“圣帕特里克，”我大喊。“好吧，这真是个好问候。他们前几天还在芝加哥你的游行中嘘我，发出嘶嘶声……”然后老圣帕特里克打断了我。“我是来做你们土地的主教的。”“嗯，我不知道，圣人，”我回答说。“你出生在哪里？”“不列颠。在不列颠。”
"Oh, no, well, Mr. Rick, we got laws, constitutional amendments preventing aliens like yourself, your saintship, from becoming citizens or getting any of King MacNeil's handouts to the peasantry. You see, we got too many foreigners coming in, taking our jobs, choice jobs, like that bishopry you're angling for."
“哦，不，好吧，瑞克先生，我们有法律、宪法修正案，防止像你这样的外星人，哦不，圣人，成为公民或获得麦克尼尔国王给农民的任何施舍。你看，我们有太多的外国人进来了，抢走了我们的工作，那些好工作，比如你垂涎的那个主教职位。”
"You don't understand. I was named, ordained by Saint Germanus himself to lead the Irish people."
“你不明白。我是被日耳曼努斯圣人亲自命名、任命来领导爱尔兰人民的。”
"Oh now, well, that's the problem. We don't want the Germanesses telling us what to do, Germanist generals under the UN flag, directing our soldiers in some Bosnian quagmire half a world away. We built up the factories and infrastructures of the Germanesses and the Yamomotos And now what are we looking at? $200 billion trade deficit."
“哦，好吧，这就是问题所在。我们不想要日耳曼人告诉我们该怎么做，不想让联合国旗帜下的日耳曼将军在半个世界之外的波斯尼亚泥潭中指挥我们的士兵。我们建立了日耳曼人和山本们的工厂和基础设施。现在我们看到了什么？2000亿美元的贸易逆差。”
"You don't understand. I bring with me the Latin Bible."
“你不明白。我带来了拉丁文圣经。”
"That's not going to win you points. Gaelic's the official language of this country, sir. Constitutional amendment."
“那不会为你加分。盖尔语才是这个国家的官方语言，先生。宪法修正案。”
"I bring the shamrock clover, whose three leaves represent the Holy Trinity."
“我带来了三叶草，它的三片叶子代表了圣三一。”
"Trinity? We don't want trilaterialism here, Senor Saint. You're talking new world order, IMF, World Court, World Bank, Goldman Sachs with their sacks of gold. This here is a sovereign nation under God."
“三一？我们这里不需要三边主义，圣人先生。你在谈论新世界秩序、国际货币基金组织、世界法庭、世界银行、拿着装满金币口袋的高盛。这是一个上帝统治下的主权国家。”
"But it is God who has sent me here," replied poor Saint Patrick in my dream, "to chase the snakes from your land."
“但正是上帝派我到这里来的，”可怜的圣帕特里克在我的梦里回答，“来驱赶你们土地上的毒蛇。”
"Oh no," I replied, "chase the snakes? Heavens to Betsy. If you banish the snakes, they'll just show up in repressed forms in our dreams. Why, here's one crawling up my leg now." And at this point, just when my phantasm was threatening to become a goofy metadream, the action suddenly shifted in that crazy way dreams go, shifted to the present. And I heard the strains of my campaign theme song.
“哦，不，”我回答，“驱赶毒蛇？天哪。如果你驱逐了毒蛇，它们只会以被压抑的形式出现在我们的梦里。瞧，现在就有一条正爬上我的腿。”就在这一刻，当我的幻象威胁要变成一个愚蠢的元梦境时，行动突然以梦境那种疯狂的方式转移了，转移到了现在。我听到了我的竞选主题曲的旋律。
[MUSIC - "WE WILL ROCK YOU" BY QUEEN]
[音乐 - 女王乐队的《我们摇滚你》]
There I was, sitting with my friends and advisers, Larry Pratt, and Samuel Francis, and John Lofton, and the Reverend Donald Wildmon, talking about where my campaign should go from here, which is funny that it was those guys in the dream. Because those are the ones that have gotten me into hot water with the media because-- well, let's just say those fellas don't repress their beliefs. If they talked to some local militias about a war against the white race, or how the TV industry is made up of people raised in Jewish homes, or about promiscuous homosexuals literally hell-bent on Satanism and suicide, well, they're just being frank, which is a lot more than we can expect from Beltway insiders like that parrot the Bobster or Bill Clinton chasing issues like a blind dog in a meat market.
我就坐在那里，和我的朋友及顾问们在一起，拉里·普拉特、塞缪尔·弗朗西斯、约翰·洛夫顿和唐纳德·怀尔德蒙牧师，谈论我的竞选活动该从这里走向何方。有趣的是，梦里竟然是这些人。因为正是这些人让我陷入了媒体的麻烦，因为——嗯，让我们直说吧，这些人不压抑他们的信仰。如果他们和一些地方民兵谈论反对白人的战争，或者谈论电视产业是如何由在犹太家庭中长大的人组成的，或者谈论那些一心追求撒旦崇拜和自杀的乱交同性恋者，嗯，他们只是坦率而已，这比我们能从华盛顿内部人士那里预期的要多得多，那些像“鲍勃斯特”那样的鹦鹉，或者像猎犬一样在肉市场里追踪议题的比尔·克林顿。
Anyway, in the dream, we were talking about my options, the boys and I, the three paths diverging in a red, white, and blue wood. To be the good party boy, like I was in '92, support the leading candidate? To swoop down like a B-2 Bombardier on San Diego in August with a whooping religious war cry against the murder of the unborn? Or to go the Wallace way, bolt the party that made me, and make my own?
无论如何，在梦里，我们正在谈论我的选择，我和伙计们，三条路径分叉在红、白、蓝三色的树林里。是做一个乖乖的政党男孩，像我在92年那样，支持领先的候选人？还是像B-2轰炸机一样在八月突袭圣地亚哥，喊出反对堕胎的狂热宗教战争口号？又或是走华莱士的路线，脱离这个成就我的党派，自立门户？
But this being a dream, things started to metamorphize. Lofton's head split open, and the head of my old boss, Richard Nixon, sprouted from his shoulders in a bloody bloom of scatological curses. "Never leave the expletive deleted party, Patty Joe." His jowls flapped like sails in a squall. "I stood by Ike. I stood by Barry." But I was distracted as my other three friends burst from their own bodies like soggy-winged gypsy moths from their crystalline, becoming animatronic incarnations of my father's trio of heroes, General MacArthur, Joe McCarthy, and Francisco Franco. "I couldn't beat Ike in '52," thundered MacArthur, "but I gave him hell at the Convention." Franco, of course, was for his militant, third-party approach. Senator Joe was checking under my sofa for Reds.
但因为是在梦里，一切开始变形。洛夫顿的头裂开了，我那老老板理查德·尼克松的头从他的肩膀上长了出来，伴随着血腥的亵渎咒骂。“永远别离开那个被删减了脏话的党派，帕蒂·乔。”他的腮帮子像暴风雨中的船帆一样拍打着。“我支持过艾克。我支持过巴里。”但我分心了，因为我的另外三个朋友像湿透翅膀的舞毒蛾从茧里破壳而出，变成了我父亲三个英雄的机器化身：麦克阿瑟将军、约瑟夫·麦卡锡和弗朗西斯科·佛朗哥。“我在52年没能打败艾克，”麦克阿瑟雷鸣般地说，“但我在党代会上让他吃尽了苦头。”佛朗哥当然是支持他那激进的第三方路线。麦卡锡参议员正在检查我的沙发下面有没有“红人”。
But the whole architecture of the dream transmuted then, and I was in the future. About 2010 or so, touring college campuses and '90s nostalgia theme parks in some virtual entertainment called "The Three Pats," which was me, Pat Robertson, and Pat Boone. My buddy Robertson recited various apocalyptic folk tales of his own devising, all of which involved earthquakes, tidal waves, and neo-liberal Democratic presidents with bisexual wives, whose stints as Peace Corps volunteers in India made them acolytes of Shiva and eventually transformed them into the anti-Christ. And Pat Boone.
但梦境的整个架构随后发生了转变，我来到了未来。大约2010年左右，正在巡回参观大学校园和90年代怀旧主题公园，那是一种叫“三个帕特”的虚拟娱乐节目，主角就是我、帕特·罗伯逊和帕特·布恩。我的伙伴罗伯逊朗诵着他自己编造的各种末日民间故事，所有这些都涉及地震、海啸和有着双性恋妻子的新自由主义民主党总统，这些妻子的印度和平队志愿者经历使她们成为了湿婆的信徒，并最终将她们变成了反基督者。还有帕特·布恩。
This being a virtual entertainment of the future, I'm not sure if Pat Boone was alive or merely a hologramistic image existing within the light-emitting diodes rubber cemented to the undersides of my eyelids. But there he was, clean cut in white bucks, singing a rendition of his 1956 chart topper, "I Almost Lost My Mind," along with a smattering of selections from his fine Gospel albums. And then I came on, the main act, sounding all the themes I've been sounding in this here campaign, issues I feel deeply about.
既然这是未来的虚拟娱乐，我不确定帕特·布恩是还活着，还是仅仅存在于我眼睑内侧橡胶粘合的发光二极管中的全息图像。但他就在那里，穿着白色平底鞋，显得干练，演唱着他1956年的冠军单曲《我快疯了》，以及他精选福音专辑中的几首歌曲。然后我登场了，作为主角，表达我在这次竞选中一直表达的主题，我深感关注的议题。
I think of my father raised in poverty, but who, through hard work, was able to provide for his family. Now men like my father are finding no outlet for their hard work, their ideals, their faith in America. I told them how the Ruth Ginsburgs Bader Jose to keep leipzigging our fences and gutentagging our buildings with his Symbionese gang symbology, tacoing handouts and living off welfare, yum yum chow, giving birth to Young Phat [? Taht ?] at taxpayer expense, sashiming his way into our high techamaki jobs, while our boys in the military have to strap on the Helmut Kohl of the United heathen Nations and fight for the Turkish delight of Rabin hoods and radical sheiks.
我想到我那在贫困中长大的父亲，但他通过努力工作养活了一家人。现在像我父亲这样的人却找不到发挥他们辛勤工作、理想和对美国信仰的出口。我告诉他们鲁斯·金斯伯格们是如何……（音频模糊）……同时我们的军队小伙子们不得不系上联合国这个异教徒的头盔，为犹太拉比和激进酋长们而战。
As my futuristic audience chortled and hiccuped derision into the biogenically filtered air of the campus mediatorium, I realized that I had become a parody of myself. Our act, The Three Pats, was being presented with the same camp intentions as when they were trotting out Timothy Leary and Gordon Liddy in mock debates a few years back. Now I am not a man who's prone to self-doubt. I am my own catechism.
当我的未来观众在校园媒体厅经过生物工程过滤的空气中发出嘲笑和打嗝声时，我意识到我已经成了我自己的模仿品。我们的表演“三个帕特”正以和几年前他们拿蒂莫西·利里和戈登·利迪在模拟辩论中取乐时同样的“坎普”意图呈现。现在，我不是一个容易自我怀疑的人。我就是我自己的教义问答。
But maybe it's the beating I've been taking lately even from men who I considered to be my friends, Bill Buckley, Bill Sapphire, George Will. They make the doubts pile up and spill over into dreams. Heck, I'm the only one left in this campaign with firm beliefs and true convictions. And yet I fear becoming some comic footnote in the history of man's struggle to lift his world up closer to the Kingdom of God. My futuristic dream self gamely thundered on. But somehow, the honest Christian faith of three men named Patrick had become the 21st century's equivalent of The Brady Bunch movie today, a farce, a way of feeling superior to our former and better selves.
但也许是因为我最近承受的打击，甚至来自那些我视为朋友的人：比尔·巴克利、比尔·萨菲尔、乔治·威尔。他们让怀疑堆积如山，最终溢出到了梦境里。该死，我是这场竞选中唯一一个拥有坚定信仰和真正信念的人。然而，我害怕成为人类努力将世界提升得更接近上帝之国进程中一个滑稽的注脚。我未来的梦境自我也勇敢地隆隆前行。但不知何故，三个名为帕特的人的诚实基督教信仰，变成了21世纪版的《布雷迪家族》电影，一场闹剧，一种让人们感觉比我们过去、更好的自己更为优越的方式。
I think I woke up then. I'm not sure. I'm well into my third cup of coffee now, and it's high time to board that bus and move on to the next crowd, the next speech, the next state, the next primary. I suppose I should dwell on my dream a little more, analyze it, plumb its depths. But I'll leave interpretation to those ranks of young Reichians who twist every God-fearing thought to prove that we're all homosexuals, that God is dead, that the racist teachings of Eldridge Cleaver should be taught in our schools while the psalms of Jesus are banned. You see, I can't waste too much time on my own soul search. I've got to get out there with my posse and fight for the soul of America.
我想我那时醒了。我不确定。我现在已经喝到了第三杯咖啡，是时候登上那辆大巴，去往下一个人群、下一场演讲、下一个州、下一场初选了。我想我应该多反思一下我的梦，分析它，探索它的深度。但我会把解释权留给那些年轻的赖希派，他们扭曲每一个敬畏上帝的想法来证明我们都是同性恋、上帝已死，证明埃尔德里奇·克利弗的种族主义教义应该在我们的学校里教授，而耶稣的诗篇应该被禁止。你看，我不能把太多的时间花在自我反省上。我得带着我的伙伴们去外面为美国的灵魂而战。
Playwright David Isaacson.
剧作家大卫·艾萨克森。
Today's program was produced by Peter Clowney and by myself with Alix Spiegel, Nancy Updike, and Dolores Wilber. Contributing editors Jack Hitt, Margy Rochlin, and Paul Tough. WBEZ management oversight by Torey Malatia.
今天的节目由彼得·克劳尼和我自己制作，艾丽克斯·斯皮格尔、南希·厄普代克和多洛雷斯·威尔伯参与制作。特约编辑：杰克·希特、玛吉·罗克林和保罗·托夫。WBEZ管理层监督：托里·马拉蒂亚。
[ACKNOWLEDGEMENTS]
[致谢]
If you want to buy a tape of this or others of our programs, call us at WBEZ 312-832-3800. Or you can email us. Our address, [email protected] . We do answer our email. We broadcast proudly from WBEZ Chicago. We'll be back next week with more stories of This American Life.
如果您想购买本节目或其他节目的录音带，请拨打WBEZ电话312-832-3800。或者您可以给我们发电子邮件。我们的地址是 [email protected]。我们确实会回复邮件。我们自豪地从芝加哥WBEZ广播电台向您播出。下周我们将带来更多《美国生活》的故事。